AN EPIC BATTLE IS PLAYING OUT IN
WASHINGTON.
NO, IT'S NOT BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND A POLITICIAN.
INSTEAD, TRUMP IS GOING
TOE-TO-TOE WITH
KELLYANNE CONWAY'S HUSBAND.
TRADING SHOTS ON TWITTER WITH
GEORGE CONWAY UNLEASHING ATTACKS
LIKE THESE, CLAIMING THE
PRESIDENT IS MENTALLY UNSTABLE.
AMERICANS SHOULD BE THINKING
SERIOUSLY NOW ABOUT TRUMP'S
MENTAL CONDITION AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL STATE, INCLUDING
AND ESPECIALLY THE MEDIA,
CONGRESS, AND THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND CABINET.
AND CONGRATULATIONS, YOU JUST
GUARANTEED THAT MILLIONS MORE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LEARN ABOUT
NARCISSISTIC PERSONALITY
DISORDER AND MALIGNANT
NARCISSISM.
GOOD JOB."
TRUMP COUNTER PUNCHING BY SAYING
GEORGE IS JEALOUS OF HIS WIFE
AND CALLING HIM A "STONE COLD
LOSER AND HAS BEEN FROM HELL."
THE PRESIDENT ALSO SURVEYING UP
THIS BEAT DOWN EARLIER.
>> I DON'T KNOW HIM.
HE IS A WHACK JOB, NO QUESTION.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
I THINK HE'S DOING A TREMENDOUS
DISSERVICE TO A WONDERFUL WIFE.
KELLYANNE IS A WONDERFUL WOMAN.
I CALL HIM MR. KELLYANNE.
THE FACT IS THAT HE'S DOING
DOING A TREMENDOUS DISSERVICE TO
A WIFE AND FAMILY.
SHE'S A WONDERFUL WOMAN.
>> Jesse: KELLYANNE CONWAY
RESPONDING BY DEFENDING TRUMP,
SAYING "HE LEFT IT ALONE FOR
MONTHS OUT OF RESPECT FOR ME BUT
YOU THINK HE SHOULDN'T RESPOND
WHEN SOMEBODY, A NONMEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL ACCUSES HIM OF
HAVING A MENTAL DISORDER?
YOU THINK HE SHOULD JUST TAKE
THAT SITTING DOWN?"
THIS HAPPENED ALL THE TIME IN
THE BUSH WHITE HOUSE.
>> Dana: YEAH, REMEMBER THOSE
DAYS?
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS?
I DON'T PICK WITH EVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
>> Dana: IF YOU GO WAY BACK,
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
WHILE.
GEORGE CONWAY, NOT SHY ABOUT
TWEETING.
BUT IT HAS RAMPED UP OVER TIME.
FIRST IT WAS MORE LIKE REALLY,
SEE SECTION 8 TO FOUR OF THE
PENAL CODE, WHATEVER.
BUT THEN IT'S QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S MENTAL HEALTH
AND THERE WAS A PROFILE OF
CONWAY AND HER HUSBAND, I THINK
IT WAS IN "THE WASHINGTON POST"
LAST SUMMER.
I REMEMBER SENDING HER NOTE.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE FINEST
COUPLE.
THEY COULD HAVE THIS ARGUMENT.
SHE IS ALLOWING THE REPORTERS TO
COME IN.
SHE'S COOKING AND SHE'S SINGING
TO OVERCOME ANYTHING THAT HE IS
SAYING.
LOOKED LIKE A PHONE FAMILY
ATMOSPHERE WHERE YOU MIGHT HAVE
DISAGREEMENTS BUT YOU DON'T LET
IT INTERFERE.
>> Jesse: NOT SO MUCH FUN
ANYMORE.
>> Dana: I HOPE IT'S NOT
BOTHERING THEM.
I DO THINK, THEY HAVE SCHOOL
AGED CHILDREN.
THEY CAN ALL READ.
THE INTERNET LIVES FOREVER.
I'M NOT TELLING ANYONE SOMETHING
THEY DON'T KNOW.
IF PETER HAD EVER DONE THIS TO
ME.
THAT'S THE THING.
PETER HAS NEVER, EVER DONE
ANYTHING LIKE THIS TO ME.
I FEEL FOR THEM ALTHOUGH I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY REALLY CARE.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S THE WEIRDEST THING I'VE
EVER SEEN.
>> Greg: YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
PETER'S "I HATE JASPER" WEBSITE?
>> Jesse: THIS IS LIKE A SCENE
FROM "VEEP."
>> Greg: I LOVE TELEVISION.
I GREW UP ON SITCOMS.
THIS IS THE GREATEST SITCOM
EVER.
GEORGE CONWAY IS BASICALLY
NEWMAN FROM SEINFELD.
TRUMP IS BASICALLY SEINFELD AND
KELLYANNE IS ELAINE BUT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A NEWMAN.
OR MAYBE HE'S LIKE MR. ROPER
FROM THREES COMPANY AND TRUMP IS
JACK TRIPPER.
HE'S ALWAYS STARING AT HIM WITH
HIS BEADY EYES.
HE'S ALWAYS MAD AT HIM.
THIS WHOLE THING HAS AMAZING
CHARACTERS.
WE HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT
AMERICA WANTS TO KNOW.
WHAT IS IT LIKE AT HOME?
IS IT JUST SOME KIND OF
KNOCKDOWN, DRAG OUT FIGHT OR IS
THERE LOVE LIFE SO INSANE THAT
IT DOESN'T MATTER?
THIS IS NONE OF MY BUSINESS,
RIGHT?
BUT I AM FORCED TO THINK ABOUT
THEM HAVING SEX.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
WE HAVE A CRAZY SITCOM.
WE HAVE DOMESTIC FIGHTS
PUBLICLY.
THIS IS THE MOST TRANSPARENT
ADMINISTRATION EVER BECAUSE
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
>> Jesse: IT'S LIKE WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAYS YOU KNOW WHEN I
LEAVE OFFICE, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE NOTHING TO WRITE ABOUT.
THAT'S TRUE.
>> Emily: I FEEL LIKE IT'S AN
EPISODE OF BILLIONS.
THE HUSBAND AND THE BOSS.
I DO FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT ABOUT
YOU.
POOR KELLYANNE CONWAY IS JUST
TRYING TO DO HER JOB.
I FORGOT I WAS GOING TO SIT ON
MY HANDS TODAY.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT BETO
SHOULD DO.
>> Emily: I FEEL BAD FOR HER.
SHE SOMEONE WHO GETS UP EVERY
MORNING AND GOES TO WORK AND
THEN HAS TO BE CAUGHT BETWEEN A
ROCK AND A HARD PLACE.
HER HUSBAND COULD HAVE
DEMONSTRATED IN THIS MOMENT TO
ME AS A LEARNING MOMENT,
TEACHING OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY AS LIKE
LOOK, EVEN THOUGH WE DISAGREE ON
EVERYTHING, I LOVE MY WIFE.
I SUPPORT HER.
HE --
>> Dana: LIKE CARVELL AND
MADELINE?
>> Greg: ARE YOU REALLY
SITTING ON YOUR HANDS?
>> Emily: YES.
>> Juan: REMEMBER, YOU MOCKED
HER FOR USING HER HANDS.
>> Jesse: HALF A BETO.
>> Emily: I STARTED IT.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN DO BETO WITH
ONE HAND TIED BEHIND YOUR BACK.
I HAVE SYMPATHY, JUAN, BECAUSE
OF MOM TEXTS.
WE ALL HAVE OUR ISSUES.
YOU HAVE SONS WHO ARE
REPUBLICANS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY INSIGHT INTO
THIS SITUATION?
>> Juan: I LIKE BILLIONS
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE EXACTLY WHAT
YOU SAID.
IT'S THE WOMAN BETWEEN TWO
POWERFUL MEN.
IT'S BETWEEN WENDY RHODES AND
CHUCK RHODES AND BOBBY AXELROD.
THE HEDGE FUND GUY.
BUT HERE WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE I THINK LOTS OF PEOPLE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S MENTAL HEALTH THIS
WEEKEND WHEN HE WAS GOING AFTER
JOHN McCAIN.
WE EVEN HAVE REPUBLICANS
DEFENDING JOHN McCAIN, CINDY
McCAIN SAYING THAT IT SPARKED
ALL KINDS OF NASTY EMAILS TO
HER.
HE WENT ON A TWITTER STORM.
GEORGE CONWAY COMES OUT AND IS
TALKING, WHAT WAS INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS WAS GEORGE CONWAY
PUTS UP LITERAL DIAGNOSES
MATERIAL FROM REAL DOCTORS ABOUT
NARCISSISTIC DISORDER,
ANTISOCIAL BEHAVIOR, CITING THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT LEADS THEM TO WHAT I FELT
FOR KELLYANNE, SOMEONE I'VE
KNOWN FOR MANY YEARS, SHE GETS
ON TV ON MONDAY AND PEOPLE ARE
SAYING DO YOU AGREE WITH YOUR
HUSBAND?
SHE SAYS NO.
SHE WORKS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
SHE CAN'T DISAGREE WITH THE GUY
WHO IS SIGNING HER PAYCHECK.
BUT SHE WENT ON TO SAY --
>> Dana: THE TAXPAYERS SIGN
HER PAYCHECK.
>> Juan: SHE WORKS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Dana: THEY WORK FOR US!
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
HE DOESN'T KNOW GEORGE CONWAY.
GEORGE CONWAY'S FIGHTS BACK AND
SAYS OF COURSE I KNOW YOU.
PUTTING DOWN JEFF SESSIONS.
PUTTING TOWN JOHN BOLTON.
IT'S, AS GREG SAID, LIKE
SOMETHING OUT OF TV LAND.
I DO THINK THEY MIGHT BE SETTING
THEMSELVES UP TO BE THE NEXT
CARNIVAL AND --
>> Greg: IT'S A REALITY SHOW.
>> Dana: I HAVE A FRIEND WHO
THINKS IT'S ALL PLANNED.
>> Jesse: YOU THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO PARLAY IT INTO A
REALITY SHOW AFTER ALL THIS FOR
CASH.
>> Dana: WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Greg: LIFE IS REALLY GOOD
IF THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
IT'S ENTERTAINMENT PRETENDING TO
BE A PROBLEM.
I THINK THIS IS WHERE TRUMP'S
EXPERIENCE WITH TV COMES IN, HE
LOOKS AROUND AND SAYS WE CAN
HAVE FUN HERE.
I DON'T THINK HE TAKES IT AS
SERIOUSLY AS ANYBODY DOES.
IT'S ON US TO NOT TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
>> Dana: PEOPLE SAYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP THINKS IT'S AN
INSULT TO BE CALLED BY YOUR
WIFE'S NAME.
THIS HAS HAPPENED TO PETER A LOT
BECAUSE I HAVE A PUBLIC PROFILE
AND WE GO PLACES AND THEY ARE
LIKE MR. PERINO.
HE SAYS YES.
>> Juan: BUT IT'S NO JOKE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN TERMS OF HIS
PUTTING DOWN JOHN McCAIN, A
DEAD MAN.
>> Jesse: JUAN, WE ARE HAVING
FUN WITH THIS.
THIS IS A TABLOID TOPIC.
>> Juan: THAT'S THE POINT.
YOU CAN HAVE FUN BUT I'M TELLING
YOU REAL PEOPLE THINK THAT
THERE'S A REAL PSYCHOLOGICAL
ISSUE.
>> Greg: THAT STUFF IS SO DEEP
AND INGRAINED HABITS -- PEOPLE
HAVE THESE VIEWS THAT GO BEYOND
THE GRAVE.
MOST HISTORICAL FIGURES HAVE
THESE KIND OF PROBLEMS.
AT THIS POINT, COMPLAINING ABOUT
TRUMP'S PERSONALITY IS LIKE